zach frankie on the mound for the
houston astros this will be his 12th
start of the season leads the astros
with six quality starts batting average
against him this season you see right
there on the bottom at 250 and opponents
have hit eight home runs against him
myers has struggled in his career
against that drinkie
called third strike will myers
looks at a strike for the final out of
the inning zach rinke off to a good
start today
blake snell on the bound for the friars
making his 11th start in a padres
uniform sixth on the road four pitch
pitcher
we heard bob talk about it really the
length
is going to be a key today pitch six
innings against colorado
that one finds itself into center field
blake snell on a no two pitch allows a
single to jose altuve who continues it
well
against the lefty snell
there is a base into right field
chas mccormick
toube trying first to third and the ball
will be cut off
jose altuve aggressive on the base pass
still frisky after getting that first
hit of the game so second and third now
nobody out padres keep the infield back
no score bottom of the first 2-2 to
bregman
and that's hit off the hands coming on
the field that is the second baseman
marcano and he throws to first to get
bregman as altuve comes home to make it
one-nothing astro and he'll bring up
kyle tucker hitting 230 304 on base
percentage 10 homers 28 rbis
that balls hit high and deep to left
field all the way back is pro far
looking up gone
three run home run kyle
tucker into the crawford boxes the other
way and the astros jump in front four to
nothing
that'll wake up a team coming off a
tough loss
you're right tk that's a huge swing
early in the game they want to put a big
number up and they got the big swing
from kyle tucker an opposite field shot
this one's popped up left side toward
the dugout of the padres bregman a long
run leans over and it's off the tip of
his glove
he reached in there
both feet off of the ground as he leaned
on that railing
and i think it ticked off the end of his
glove
yeah i think that's exactly what
happened
just out of his reach
it wouldn't have been fair if he was on
there no
swing and a miss quick work by grenke
and webster revas
a three-pitch strikeout second strikeout
for zach two away in the third
swinging a miss he gets spammed
strikes out to end the third there goes
the bat
runners on the corners here's diaz big
hole in the right side
here's the pitch and he hits a liner to
left field that's a base hit bregman
scores easily
around second over to thirds correa and
they're going to send him
here comes the relay not a dime correa
scores a two run double for ledmis diaz
and it's six to nothing
big two out hit from diaz no hesitation
from third base coach omar lopez sending
correa
especially with two out can be more
aggressive knew that profar was going to
have a little trouble because that ball
went all the way down to that corner
and as a base runner you're assuming
he's going to ascend you make him stop
you
and correa was full speed ahead the
whole way
six nothing astros now here's taylor
jones
taylor jones goes the other way that'll
be a base hit and let miss diaz will be
waved around
seven nothing astros
blake snell on the ropes here in the
third inning and the padres don't want
to go to their
bullpen if possible
as taylor jones drives in his second run
of the season it's good to see taylor
jones getting some love from that dugout
he had a rough game yesterday
a couple of ground into grounding into
double plays that he had
dropped fly ball
but here today shows up and drives in a
big run and getting some love from that
dugout that's good to see him smiling
bring up webster boss 4 in the big
league so far
getting his second start behind the dish
in the majors
driven to left field deep and far and
webby revoss has his first hit in the
big leagues it's a home run
padres are on the board
[Applause]
congratulations to webster rebos
first major league hits a home run
what a shining moment for webster rivas
making his major league debut
two nights ago almost had a hit in his
first at bat had to wait and he waits
for a home run against zach grenky i
noticed in houston they've been throwing
the balls back i did not notice if they
threw that ball back
there's a pop-up right around the mound
and coming from third
is kim to make the catch uphill that's
tough
climbing up the backside of the mound he
makes the grab
and tumbles on the hill
and to be willing to buy in for the sake
of the team it speaks volumes to the to
the other guys in this rotation
don grenke's 2-1 pitch is hit through
the right side in a lead-off single for
jerks in pro far here in the sixth
inning that is the first time today the
padres have had the leadoff man aboard
zach would love to get a ground ball
towards altuve here working through the
lineup for the third time here ground
ball towards out to bay flips to correa
there's a double play they were looking
for
zach frankie works into and out of
trouble in the sixth inning
getting hosmer to ground into a double
play to end the sixth
grievous hit that home run on a 3-2
curveball
what he tries to do here maybe that
fastball away
[Applause]
fly ball to pretty deep left but
playable
going back on adieurs mccormick one two
three inning for zach first one two
three inning since the second inning
the home run by kyle tucker
and they got three more runs in the
third to knock blake snell out after
three innings here's grinky's 100th
pitch
curveball taps softly past grinky to his
left is altuve he has it and whips it
over to first in time
nicely done by altuve a little sidearm
toss
to get matteo for out number one it all
had to be perfect the transfer as well
ground ball towards first diaz will make
the play to second for one the return
throw in time for the double play
frankie gets a second double play in
three innings
that goes diaz to correa back to oled
miss as they smile about it on the way
to the dugout 7-1 astros
probably wouldn't take too too much for
dusty to get somebody else out oh yeah i
think that hook will be a little quicker
than it normally is based on the
opponent
two and one that's it in the air to
right field pretty well struck tucker
going back at the wall looking up gonna
go
will myers homers for a second straight
day
padres get one here in the night seven
to two astros with nobody out
all right well it seems like the stove
has been turned on
see what happens as this padre offense
starts to warm up a little bit one out
in the ninth inning lead off home run by
myers walk on four pitches by hosmer
and hassan kim coming up here
fly ball to deep left field down the
line towards the pole it's off the pole
a two-run home run for hassan kim here
come the padres it's now seven of four
three runs so far in the ninth and
there's still only one out ha sung kim
with his third home run
in the big leagues relentless
swag and a miss
astros wins 7-4
the astros take one game out of this
three-game weekend series against the
padres